[англійською] Коли в Києві прийняли християнство,
[англійською] виникла Київська архітектурна школа,
[англійською] і з Києва це розійшлося повсюди.
[англійською] Є одна вуличка на Подолі,
[англійською] спускаючись якою я іноді
почуваюся так, ніби в Дамаску.
[англійською] Не вистачає лише аромату жасмину,
[англійською] бо Дамаск — це місто жасмину.
[англійською] Отже, повертаючись у 2012 рік,
коли почалася війна в Сирії.
[англійською] Будівлю в центрі Дамаска,
де знаходився мій офіс, обстріляли.
[Хусам аль-Ямані, архітектор]
[англійською] Так
я втратив офіс, свій бізнес,
[англійською] і ситуація була дедалі небезпечнішою,
[англійською] тож я вирішив, що настав час виїхати з країни.
[російською] Тут знаходиться
стійка реєстрації клініки.
[російською] Я хотів, аби ця кімната
нагадувала про моє східне походження,
[російською] тому меблі я замовив в Сирії,
на моїй першій батьківщині,
[російською] а майстри,
які виготовляли ці меблі,
[російською] походять з місцини, звідки я родом, —
з околиць Дамаска.
[російською] До речі, це бульвар Шевченка.
[російською] Тут знаходиться клініка,
де я вчився в ординатурі, аспірантурі,
[російською] недалеко від станції метро «Університет».
[російською] У цій будівлі п'ять років
проходило моє навчання і практика,
[російською] і тут я познайомився з Мариною Миколаївною
на першому поверсі в фоє.
[сміється]
— [російською] Це історичне місце.
— [російською] Це було давно. Ось тут, у цій будівлі,
[російською] 1991-го року.
[російською] Тому завжди, коли ми їдемо повз,
у нас таке приємне відчуття. Перша зустріч.
[російською] Вона зайшла через ті двері, я її зустрів там посередині, побачив — і все.
[російською]
Сказав, що це буде моя дружина.
[російською] Так, Марино Миколаївно?
Ви про це не знали?
[російською] Ну ти мені про це прямо не сказав.
Може, подумав.
[російською] Але я його коли побачила,
то коліна підкосилися.
— [російською] Одразу закохалась?
— [російською] Так.
— [російською] Сподіваюсь, і продовжуєте це робити?
— [російською] Звісно.
[англійською] Ми зараз у ресторані Linas caffe.
[англійською] Як бачите, атмосфера
протягом дня тут прекрасна.
[англійською]
Тому зазвичай я приходжу сюди працювати.
[англійською] І роблю це щодня.
[англійською] До архітекторів завжди приходять ідеї
[англійською] і все що тобі потрібно, коли це відбувається,
— це аркуш паперу та олівець,
[англійською] і ти просто зображаєш все на папері.
[англійською] Сирійці почали
приїжджати в Україну з часів СРСР.
[англійською] І коли Україна стала
незалежною 1991-го року,
[англійською] між нею та Сирією зав'язались
серйозні ділові відносини,
[англійською] зокрема з Алеппо та Дамаском,
[англійською] бо Алеппо розташоване дуже близько до Одеси.
[англійською] Тому частина бізнесменів
з Дамаска та Алеппо
[англійською] переїхали до Одеси та Харкова.
[англійською] Вони все ще мали свій бізнес у Сирії,
і відкрили новий тут
[англійською] та розпочали між двома країнами
торгівлю, що поступово розвивається.
[російською] Черв'яки ваші?
[російською] Шістдесят шість.
[російською] Дві порції опаришів, будь ласка.
— [російською] Двадцять гривень.
— [російською] Це все. То для нашого діда.
[російською] Рибалка — то його розвага.
[російською] Ви його знаєте.
[російською] Ще щось?
[російською] Вітання, Людмило Сергіївно!
[російською] Ви чекали на нас?
[російською] Коли я вийшла заміж і сказала
бабусі, що ми приїдемо в село до неї в гості,
[російською] то в моєї бабусі був найбільший страх,
як я піду з ним до магазину.
[російською] Розумієте? Це був її страх.
[російською] Тобто, все прекрасно, але як ти
з ним в магазин зайдеш?
— [російською] Це ж буде жахливо!
— [російською] Вихід на сцену. [сміється]
[російською] Жах жахливий, розумієте? Що ж скажуть люди?
[російською] У мами найбільший був страх,
що мене обміняють на верблюда.
[російською] Не знаю, звідки взявся
цей стереотип у радянських людей,
— [російською] що якщо ти одружуєшся з іноземцем...
— [російською] Бажано на хорошого верблюда.
[російською] то тебе обов'язково
мають обміняти на верблюда. Чому? Не знаю.
[російською] Привіт, діду!
— [російською] Привіт.
[сміються]
— [російською] Як життя?
— [російською] Нормально.
— [російською] Красиві?
— [російською] Прекрасні! Тільки мало.
[сміються]
— [російською] Як ваше здоров'я?
— [російською] Прекрасно.
— [російською] На риболовлю підемо сьогодні?
— [російською] Та звісно ж!
[російською] Куди ж ви без мене? Ви ж любите свіжу рибу.
— [російською] Тільки з ваших рук, діду.
— [російською] Ну так.
[англійською] Я починав зі статусу біженця,
[англійською] а потім, коли настав час,
згідно із законом подав документи на  громадянство.
[англійською] Це лиш питання часу, коли президент
підпише наказ про надання громадянства.
[англійською] Зараз, за законом,
я маю всі обов‘язки громадянина. І я цим пишаюсь.
[англійською] Перші кілька місяців
було нелегко відкрити власну справу,
[англійською] бо зазвичай після приїзду до нової країни
необхідно вивчити ринок, потреби людей,
[англійською] розібратися, в якій сфері
розпочинати роботу.
[англійською] Зазвичай вихідці з Сирії
відкривають ресторан,
[сміється]
[англійською] бо в нас дуже яскрава культура і смачна кухня.
[російською] Століттями сирійці
славилися своєю комерцією.
[російською] Шовковий Шлях було пролягав
саме крізь сирійську Пальміру та Дамаск.
[російською] Я не володію точними цифрами,
але в Києві мешкає близько 200 сирійців.
[російською] Серед нас є юристи, бізнесмени,
є ресторатори, комерсанти.
[російською] Кого ще згадати?
[російською] Лікарі? Так, є лікарі, крім мене.
[сміється]
[російською] Я не єдиний лікар.
[російською] Архітектори, як, наприклад, Хусам.
Архітектор.
[англійською] Коли я представляюся
як Хусам з Сирії,
[англійською] мене питають: «О боже! Ти з Сирії?
Яка ситуація там зараз? Розкажи!
[англійською] Чи правда те, що ми чуємо
в новинах про Сирію?»
[англійською] Моя відповідь
базується на тому, що я знаю.
[англійською] Після вторгнення Росії в Сирію
2015-го року, вони нас фактично окупували.
[англійською] Росія намагається
окупувати всю цю територію,
[англійською] починаючи від України у 2014-му році і аж до
до середземноморського узбережжя Сирії.
[російською] Йдемо, діду?
[російською] Там моя мама, мої сестри, двоє моїх братів.
[російською] В останній поверх нашого
багатоквартирного будинку влучила бомба.
[російською] І в цьому домі, де живе моя мама,
була величезна дірка в даху.
[російською] Вона лишилася в Дамаску,
у своєму будинку, де вона прожила все життя.
[російською] Це типова вулиця Дамаска.
[російською] Бачимо тут двері, сусідів, криницю,
дуже часто можна натрапити на криниці у старому Дамаску,
[російською] гончарна та овочева крамниця,
і, звісно, верхні поверхи, які зазвичай займає молодь.
[російською] Коли заходиш всередину —
прямо розташовані коридорчик і майданчик,
[російською] у центрі якого обов'язково має бути фонтан.
[російською] Маленький шматочок великого
Дамаска в українському антуражі.
[англійською] Ми зараз їдемо на
Бесарабський ринок на Хрещатику.
[англійською] У нас там новий об‘єкт.
[англійською] Робота йде. Ми зараз починаємо розбирання,
а за тиждень — ремонт.
[російською] Дякую.
[російською] Він зараз підійде.
[російською] Гаразд. Ми почекаємо.
[російською] Він зараз буде.
[арабською] Якщо ми зможемо полагодити маркізу...
— [арабською] Це виглядатиме чудово.
— [арабською] Так, давайте так і зробимо.
— [російською] Добрий день.
[російською] За годину наша страва буде готова.
[російською] Я просто хочу рис зварити.
[російською] Сідай, кохана. Моя українко.
[російською] Ти скучив за мною, так?
[російською] Сирія зараз у складному становищі,
тому я вважаю себе сирійцем.
[російською] Я вважаю себе українцем тоді,
коли це стосується України.
[російською] Коли хтось говорить зле про Україну,
то я відразу стаю українцем і починаю її захищати.
— [російською] Чесно, так.
— [російською] По ситуації.
[російською] Коли хтось говорить зле про Україну,
то я відразу стаю стовідсотковим українцем.
[російською] Я так само буду Сирію захищати,
якщо хтось говоритиме про неї зле.
[російською] Тому, можна сказати,
що ми належимо обом цим народам.
[арабською] Холодильники будуть тут?
[арабською та англійською] Один буде тут на вітрині,
а другий там, біля лінії самообслуговування.
[арабською] А там буде відкритий бар,
і він буде з‘єднаний з кухнею.
[арабською] А там буде все начиння для бару,
все замовлення.
— [арабською] Так, це буде місце для начиння.
— [арабською] А замовляти будуть тут?
[арабською] Не все. На лінії самообслуговування
будуть десерти в холодильних камерах.
[арабською] У нас буде 3-4 гарячі десерти.
— [арабською] Так-так, гарячі десерти.
— [арабською] Так, тут гарячі десерти.
[арабською] Гарячі десерти будуть з кухні, так.
[англійською] Я пишаюся тим,
що я громадянин України.
[англійською] Усі хороші речі, які зараз є в Україні,
є результатом Євромайдану.
[англійською] Звісно, всі переймаються за свою країну.
Я також. Стежу за новинами щоденно.
[англійською] Але, зрештою, ми люди,
які люблять життя. Так? Життя продовжується.
[англійською] Україна — це моя країна зараз.
[англійською] У Сирії є таке прислів'я: Твій дім — це місце,
де ти у безпеці.
[англійською] Україна дала нам можливість жити,
бути успішними і робити бізнес.
[англійською] Щодня ми намагаємося бути частиною
цієї спільноти і частиною успіху цієї  країни.
[англійською] Як я казав, Україна — це моя країна,
мій дім тепер.
[російською] Це м'ясо по-єменськи.
[російською] Страва називається «манди».
[російською] Дівчата, до столу!
[російською] Моя мрія — аби повернувся
мир в Україну і в Сирію.
[російською] Хочеться, аби ці два народи
жили в мирі та достатку. Ось така мрія.
[російською] Бо вони вже настраждалися
і заслуговують на мир, спокій та процвітання.